>> Sean: JUDICIAL WATCHES OUT
WITH A NEW REPORT TONIGHT,
JOINING US NOW WITH THE LATEST
BIG DEVELOPMENTS INVESTIGATING
THE INVESTIGATORS, GREAT WORK
ONCE AGAIN BY JUDICIAL WATCH AND
ITS PRESIDENT TOM FITTON, YOU
HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION HERE.
I WILL LET YOU CONDENSE IT AND
EXPLAIN IT TO THE AUDIENCE.
>> WE ARE GETTING
PETER STRZOK-LISA PAGE
COMMUNICATIONS BUT THE EMAILS
SHOW THAT JAMES COMEY TESTIFIED
ABOUT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
EMAILS ON ANTHONY WEINER'S
LAPTOP FROM THE CLINTON SERVER
AND THE FBI WENT CRAZY BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE NUMBER.
THEY WEREN'T SURE HOW MANY
EMAILS WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY TRIED TO MUDDY THE RECORD
WITH CONGRESS BY SENDING THEM A
LETTER THAT TRIED TO WALK IT
BACK BUT DIDN'T.
IT SHOWS AGAIN THE FBI WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT PROTECTING
HILLARY CLINTON.
YOU HAVE EMAILS CONCERNING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THERE'S A
HEADS UP ABOUT IN ANTI-TRUMP
RUSSIA STORY CONCERNING
JARED KUSHNER THAT HE SENT OVER
TO THE FBI AS A HEADS UP NOT
LOOKING FOR A COMMENT BUT JUST
AS A FRIENDLY YOU MIGHT WANT TO
PAY ATTENTION TO THIS.
IT SHOWS COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
MEDIA AND THE FBI AND QUITE
FUNNY OR SADLY, THERE IS EMAIL
TRAFFIC BETWEEN STRZOK AND PAGE
WHERE THEY GET INTO A SPAT OVER
WHO SENT WHAT EMAILS TO WHOM
ABOUT THE GRAND JURY THAT WAS
LOOKING INTO HILLARY CLINTON.
IT SHOWS YOU THAT THE FBI UNDER
COMEY WAS UNETHICAL MASS,
UNPROFESSIONAL, AND THEIR
HANDLING OF THESE INVESTIGATIONS
DESERVED -- DESERVES ANOTHER
LOOK.
>> Sean: WE'VE GOT TO GET TO
IT, WE ARE GETTING MORE EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND EVERY SINGLE